hey here we are again what's up
everybody can everybody hear us is
everything okay
it looks like the mic's on mike's on
yeah better
yeah sorry it came up because like i
said i never used this obs
[ __ ] before so it's like i still have
like all the commercials and crap like
that like in my scenes
if anybody knows what i'm talking about
that uses this ready for loads
so yeah so it's like when i open it back
up and i just hit streaming and it just
automatically went to youtube and
assumed that i wanted another one of
the last night's stream it just had the
same picture so it allows you to change
that picture in there yeah
that allows you to change it before you
even start the countdown right
uh no i had to change it after i started
the countdown but it was still it was on
the little thingy but it's it's not that
big a deal it's just like
the the title card and it's only like a
couple of seconds before i can change it
out
all right yeah that's you know all right
all right yeah we're still in sync whoo
in sync we're a boy band
or something i'm still [ __ ] sleepy
from last night i am too a little bit
so for some reason i don't know if it's
because i'm turning into an old crone or
something like that but it's like
i keep waking up but at like 3 45
every morning if it was 3 15 it would be
like the amityville horror
but yeah so i'm waking up at 3 45 and i
woke up at 3 45 like not even because
sometimes it's because i have to
pee but it's like this morning it wasn't
even that i don't know what it was
and i just i just woke up and i was in a
really uncomfortable position because i
guess pookie had decided that she was
gonna sleep like kind of on my leg
you know what i mean like in but her in
between my two legs so i couldn't really
move without dislodging her
and uh you know that kind of sucked and
then i laid awake there for a long time
you get old and you don't need any sleep
you could just wake up oh i still need
to
i still need sleep then you want to take
a nap you know i'm gonna take like a
whole man nap
i know i went in to get him i said you
know we're going on in like 20 minutes
and he's like
yeah yeah he's like i don't want to do
it i'm so tired
well we got to talk about the damn
movie well first thing i did is got to
mention somebody brought to my attention
that uh
they got ron jeremy locked up did you
see the pictures of him in court
it's [ __ ] terrible did he well i mean
he didn't look that great before i mean
just
to be you
wasn't too good on him i don't i didn't
realize like how
yeah how ancient he's gotten yeah and
his uh
his his bond is [ __ ] set real high so
he's going to be there
6.6 million dollars millionaires yeah
it's like a couple cases of uh
sexual assault one of them is being
accused of rape
yeah women i think it's well i think
it's four to four
um but one of the women she um they
didn't pursue her case because i guess
the other witnesses like live out of the
country and they didn't want to
come back or there were troubles about
them coming back like to testify
yeah now are they porn stars some of
them are but some of them not
okay because apparently what he would do
and um i guess they started like
somebody started like a facebook group
um that had been like groped by him and
apparently it's like been a long term
this is just kind of like
you know bill cosby and all that kind of
stuff where it's like people like in the
industry like knew about it forever but
it's like me tood his ass
so yeah but it seemed like they that a
lot of people outside of that didn't
know about it
right so apparently what he would do
i mean and he's like almost 70 years old
this is super gross you guys
yeah and it's like so he'd go out to
clubs
and then he would like kind of be like
hey i'm [ __ ] ron jeremy i'm famous
and all this other kind of [ __ ]
and then he would i don't know if he
drugged girls or if he just like
looked out for like really drunk ones
and then would just like drag him
somewhere and rape him or something like
that
yeah you know what i mean so uh yeah
special
so if if he's uh found guilty i think
him 90 years
yeah well he won't have to serve it well
no because he's already 67
years old yeah man god damn it ron
jeremy i thought you were cool
[ __ ] off what is like well he hasn't
been he hasn't been found guilty
allegedly he hasn't has been found
guilty yeah but the thing about it is
that
like you know one of the people that um
that had something
done to her like she started a group for
other people like to get other people
forward like they had like a hundred
women
come forward and say that he had done
show to them yeah which
well there's gonna be some fakes in
there yeah but i feel like that's
probably like a really small percentage
i mean you don't know you're blowing it
into something
there's gotta be evidence it's gonna be
proof
it's gotta be evidence gotta be
testimony at least if you see who it is
it's saying this
well there are like i i can't remember
the names because i i wrote this [ __ ]
down but i don't remember where it is
now yeah but i had an article that was
in the l.a times danica dayne was one of
the ones
uh jennifer steele jay taylor those
sound like all porn stars they are
but you know what i mean there but there
were other ones too but those those were
three that brought charlie
he was okay yeah so he's so this was
within the industry there me team
me too and him he's the porn's version
of [ __ ] uh
weinstein is what they're saying yeah
yeah like it's just
yeah i can see that i can see that too
yeah and he definitely does seem like
the type of dude that would like
because everybody knows who ron jeremy
is yeah that would like throw his weight
around especially now that he's like an
old man and probably can't get it
yeah he can't get him for free anymore
yeah
that's what he's doing is just you know
i'm ron jeremy and you're a porn star
you know you got to kiss the ring
you know and he reaches in his pants
there's the ring and then everybody's
like no i was afraid yeah yeah that's
probably what he's doing
[Laughter]
and he probably didn't think it's a big
deal you know what i mean hey well they
never do
do they they never yeah it's not a big
deal you guys are all porn stars
yeah well i'm not getting paid for this
[ __ ]
give it up yeah that's that's that's
that's what he's doing
yeah yeah [ __ ] oh [ __ ] raw
ron ron his room still that rum was good
we both thought the same thing at the
same time it's not like he had anything
to do with it he's just like yeah i'll
license my image to slap another thing
he didn't yeah he didn't make it like in
his basement
so yeah we we had to mention that
because i i didn't know about that
and somebody i guess somebody sent you
the
the link to it because i hadn't heard
anything this the
the article that i saw from the la times
i think was from two days ago
so it's like it's pretty recent yeah
you're a mod zack i've
made like three three mods just in case
we get any like
miscreants i think i think it carries on
to uh i need to get
i think i think you keep that status so
i think it would carry on to other live
streams
we don't we don't usually get i mean on
the live streams we don't get anybody
coming in here like
no there's usually usually it's uh just
regulars
yeah it's usually just everybody and we
know who y'all are which is nice
yeah i mean you know i was gonna say
yeah did ron jeremy ever look good yes
he did he was actually a play girl
when he was young he looked like uh
like a um burt reynolds
he looked like that at one time although
burt reynolds didn't really look all
that good either
[Laughter]
you know this is a matter of opinion i
mean yeah that was that was
that was uh kind of a popular look back
in the 70s yeah i know i remember
yeah black kind of curly hair and a
[ __ ] handlebar mustache looked like
he came out of a [ __ ] off the village
people
hairy little [ __ ] and uh that's
that was a very
little [ __ ] yeah and uh but that
was a popular look back there but i
remember him kind of looking like
and now you know it's been a long time
since i've seen the photos of him but
from that era but i i remember thinking
at the time you kind of looked like burt
reynolds
that you were like were you like
surprised when you saw like photos yeah
i couldn't believe that was him
wow he actually doesn't look like a
little toad person
yeah you know my whole life even when i
was a teenager you know her
late teens early 20s he looked like a
[ __ ] little hedgehog and they called
him a hedgehog
yeah he was just a little short round
fat hairy [ __ ] silly looking dude man
he was blue he chased after rings
[Laughter]
sonic that song yeah we saw that movie i
thought for sure you would get i didn't
make a good
connection but yeah he's just [ __ ]
funny looking
he was a funny guy but evidently you
know
it just goes to show looks don't matter
for men in porn
well he was an actual actor he was a
legitimate actor
well yeah i mean he's been in some other
[ __ ] he couldn't get any work so then he
went to porn
yeah and well that happens he started he
started in a time when porn movies were
were movies remember that remember that
they were on like 35
a millimeters yeah [ __ ] they actually
just [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah they they wants to sit through an
hour and a half
it's stupid they tried to actually
you know be respectable they're like it
was a real film
yeah yeah it didn't last long though you
know video
came and they were like no no no just
sex scenes nothing but one sex scene
after the next there's no story not that
that one
you know it doesn't have to be a story
they just need the barest skeleton of
the story to hang some [ __ ] on here
comes the pizza boy and he's horny here
comes the repairman
no they had that in the old ones but i'm
just saying eventually it just
evolved into where there was no story at
all just seeds yeah
i remember like because i was curious i
wanted to see like some of the really
you know the not really old but like the
ones from the 70s that actually were
like
actual movies like the movie yeah and
it's like god damn those were so boring
yeah there's a lot of dead spaces you're
like when's everyone
gonna start it's gonna be taking forever
i could watch a regular movie it was a
[ __ ] another time i mean they were
playing that [ __ ] in theaters and there
were dudes in there [ __ ] jerking off
and [ __ ] [ __ ]
in the [ __ ] thing because dudes are
gross that's why man
i don't understand you know i just
couldn't
there was no vhs or nothing nothing yeah
you couldn't really
you didn't have much choice and yeah
i don't think there were women in the
audience unless they were
super super freaked unless they were
selling it
but you know it's ridiculous man it's
another time
can you imagine the smell terrible
imagine walking around [ __ ] floor be
sticky and [ __ ] yeah
yeah pee wee herman he got caught yeah
that's it it's ridiculous man
and i think he got caught doing that
[ __ ] later like when they're when
when it was out of style well and when
it's like we have vcrs now
yeah and he's going in there doing this
because like exhibitionists
right get into that kind of [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] man they like that kind of great
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know it was another time and it
wasn't our generation
it was those [ __ ] were weird
well yeah i mean i was a little
i was born in 1972. so i was like a
little kid still in the 70s
i remember [ __ ] from the 70s those are
parents generations
[ __ ] yeah kinky [ __ ] man
weird
you and your [ __ ] key parties
most of those dudes are dead by now
probably probably you guys remember the
pussycat theater
i remember that name yeah i was in i was
in l.a yeah i used to
pass it all the time i remember the
science in long beach i think yeah that
was
that was a pretty famous place we had um
where i grew up in daytona we had uh on
ridgewood where all the prostitutes and
drug addicts
hung out ridgewood avenue um there used
to be a porn theater but i couldn't
remember the name
of it though i remember it had like one
of those signs
cause remember like some of the old
movie theaters especially porn theaters
for some reason
would have like those kind of triangular
signs
like pyramids that kind of stuck out
then they had like the big
tiles with the letters on them coming
down the pyramid you know what i mean
i can't remember the name of that
theater though i think they only showed
like two movies at once they were both
porn theaters but it's like that was
that was like the
the street you didn't want to go on
although i used to go down there
sometimes when i was older because
that's where judy's jazzy boutique was
and i used to love that [ __ ] place
like it was you know she had like all
the punk rock clothes and that's where
jen from the jenna torturers used to go
and get her outfits
you know what i mean so it was like i
don't think it's there anymore because
i'm sure that woman is that owns it as
dead because she was old when i was
when i went but um her name wasn't judy
that was her daughter's name
her name was norma okay we gotta discuss
this damn movie that we saw the other
day
yeah okay so we're not talking about the
conjuring
universe curse of lyrona which we also
saw in the theater which was all right
it was all right yeah
um you know not probably not the best
conjuring universe movie but it was it
was all right
this was a new movie this came out in
2020
um and it's guatemalan and it's just
called
lyorona yeah and it just i guess it
premiered at like some film festivals
like earlier this year and then
shutter got a hold of it so shutter just
started showing it like
maybe a couple of days ago yeah what'd
you think of it um
it was pretty good actually um i
wouldn't i
i don't think i would call it a horror
movie it was more
um like a real serious drama with a
little bit of like supernatural
ghost story stuff like over top of it
but it was mostly a drama
yeah i hated it i just just thought it
was boring as [ __ ]
just boring i can see yeah i can see how
we would think that like it seems like
it's gotten good
reviews but it's like i can i liked it
but i couldn't like
really super get engaged with it that 10
15 minute rule was [ __ ] back like a
vengeance i was five minutes into it and
i'm like i'm not gonna like this
10 minutes in there still nothing's
really happening i'm going this isn't
this isn't doing good
it's very slow and then 15 minutes i hit
the 15 minute
mark and i'm like okay i'm out of here
and [ __ ] you know i went out and
started playing dude he went over to
play dude
in the corner and i checked back over
and and see if anything was happening on
the screen nothing was happening
just wasn't happening for me yeah like i
said if you go
into it like knowing that it's gonna be
not like the conjuring movie if it's
gonna be like
a serious drama with maybe a little bit
of that uh
the mythology about la iron about it
because basically the story is
that there's a guy it's you know said in
guatemala there's a guy who was like a
dictator or something
um or a general and uh named don enrique
and i guess he's being tried for war
crimes because like for
you know killing like the indigenous
like the mayans and stuff
like killing a bunch of them like doing
genocide
and so it's uh him and then he gets sick
and then so he's kind of like him and
his family are like confined in their
mansion
um you know while all these protesters
are outside like you know
[ __ ] with them and he starts
like hearing uh a woman crying
in the house and then like all their
maids and
you know all their servants uh take off
because the servants are kind of more on
the protesters side
and so he's like well we need more maids
we can't like do things ourselves
and um and so this woman this young
woman shows up
um to be a maid at the house and the
implication being that she's liarona and
she's gonna take like
revenge on the guy but like i said this
is a very
it's very um low-key yeah
it's also very very south american
stereotypical [ __ ]
growing up in brazil uh
it's using a lot of tropes and a lot of
ideas they're just very tired and played
out
in places like brazil and central and
south america
if this was a brazilian movie it would
have been made by the pt
or something it's real stereotypical
marxist social commentary and it's just
it's just played out you know what i
mean where
you have to see it you have to
understand central and south america and
south america to really understand it
it's very stereotypical
boring from my point of view if you're
you know if you're an american you're
not real [ __ ] familiar with
south american culture and you know
maybe
you might see it as something um unique
but
from my point of view it's just
stereotypical
yeah i mean it didn't really seem like
it was doing anything super new like it
was it was interesting
that they used the lyrona myth
like in that way like in a sort of
political allegory type of way that was
interesting but
i don't really think i mean because it's
a pretty broad myth you can use it a lot
you know you can use it a lot of ways
and there might have been some other
because there's been like 40 bajillion
lyorona movies
the only thing missing was che guevara
if chekovara showed up or fidel castro
that would have [ __ ] just been the
icing on the cake
yeah it's like i said it's it's just
boring south american [ __ ]
yeah it's as i said it's very low-key
it's very
i mean if you're looking for a horror
movie i would not even call it a horror
movie yeah
you know what i mean i think it was just
like a drama like
a little bit of a supernatural yeah what
it was
was south american political propaganda
that's exactly what it was they called
that a uh
trying to think of the [ __ ] term that
that they
that they tended to use an important
movie it's what they call it
that's that's what they would call it an
important movie what that means is
it's social commentary but it's only
like
marx's social commentary that's that's
what it is
so to me it was just a work of south
america propaganda
and it comes out of the studios and like
i said if this was brazilian it would
have been made by the
the pt or the uh the workers party
telling you that's what that was yeah
i'm not real sure who made this like the
name of the director
was uh bustamente
yeah um so i'm not sure if he's made any
other movies or not
because this is i think this is probably
the first guatemalan yeah
movie yeah that i've ever seen it was
other than that production was high
quality
acting it was a nice looking movie um
you know good acting and stuff
it just you know i like i said i liked
it and it was i thought it was like a
quality like a well done movie
but it just it didn't really grab me all
that much but it did have like a cup it
had some cool like visuals in it and
stuff and
if you want to see a cool communist
propaganda monster movie you want to see
the north korean movie called pugasari
that's a [ __ ] badass movie and uh we
need to review that one yesterday
that's a good communist movie and um
it's a communist godzilla
happening in um [ __ ]
uh medieval korea and pukasari starts
off these
this little bitty creature and he eats
steel and he grows to
huge proportions and you have to defeat
him and he's an allegory for capitalism
capitalism
eating up all the steel and all the
resources and uh
growing out of control and that's a good
commie movie that was uh
uh kim jong-il made that movie he did
yeah and he made that with captives
captured kidnapped kidnapped the
directors from japan and the actor right
actor and the actress that's in it yeah
i think they they were
they had to do it or they would be
killed yeah and it was better
and it was better than any [ __ ] movie
from towie
you know for a japanese towie movie much
better it was a good movie
i liked the monster design yeah like i
don't remember a lot about it but i
remember the monster looking pretty cool
kind of like godzilla with bull horns he
had big [ __ ]
horns coming out and he was [ __ ]
armored and he was red
and he eventually started to glow red
hot it was pretty cool
yeah furnace interesting so uh
batter bobcat says i hate ghost movies
ghosts don't scare me you know what's
really weird
um and i talked about this on my blog
like a long time ago
it's really interesting because i don't
really believe in ghosts or the
supernatural all that much
um so you would think
that horror movies that scared me the
most
would be horror movies about [ __ ] that
could really happen like serial killer
movies like wolf creek or some [ __ ] like
that
but that is never the case yeah i mean i
like movies about serial killers and
[ __ ] that could really happen
but they never ever ever scare me if a
movie's gonna scare me it's gonna be
supernatural which is dumb because i
don't believe in the supernatural in
real life so i don't really believe that
could actually happen
but a supernatural movies are just much
scarier to me and i've been trying to
figure out why the [ __ ] that is for like
pretty much my whole life and i can't
figure it out zach's asking what the pt
is
the pt was the brazilian communist party
was in charge for like almost 12 years i
think
decimated brazil my friends [ __ ] went
live through it they [ __ ] hated it
brazil went from a decent country to
just a [ __ ] lawless piece of [ __ ]
country
uh the leaders of the pt are in prison
most of them right now they stole like
billions or trillions of [ __ ] dollars
um
but but brazil's in a state of [ __ ]
civil war basically right now
[ __ ] you can read up about it
although you probably won't be able to
hear anything true because
the pt controls all the news media of
brazil so
all the communications is basically uh
uh pt propaganda so truth can't come out
of brazil it's
and the pt is owned by the oligarchy
it's not owned by the people
it's the rich oligarchy owns the pt and
it rules brazil and
it's a [ __ ] up situation imagine if
[ __ ] you know what you see going on
in the northern cities right now
it would be what it would be like if
they took over
exactly zack says uh hereditary made me
cry like a [ __ ] child
it's also now my new favorite movie
which should tell you a lot about me
that is actually probably my favorite
new movie as well
and uh like i said i think i mentioned
this on one of my other things but it's
like i really really loved that movie a
lot but i'm
i want to watch it again but i'm kind of
afraid to
and i think that's the only time that's
ever happened like with any movie it's
like
i really want to watch it again but then
again i kind of don't because
after i saw it like i just was like
[ __ ]
i don't know it just stressed me out a
lot and i and it and i thought about it
for like a week or two afterward
like it really really bothered me so um
yeah i don't so i don't know if i want
to feel like that again
but then in a way like my whole life i
feel like i've been looking for a movie
that made me feel like [ __ ] like that
um and it succeeded and as far that's
really one of the only movies that
made me feel that way like at least in
the last [ __ ] 20 30 years i mean
since i was a kid
it's about hereditary yeah i didn't
really like it that much i
know you didn't i have to see it again
and i want it's like i really really
want to see it again but it's like
i don't know i just it made me feel so
bad
like afterward that it's like i don't
know if i want to feel like that again
even though i know what's coming now so
it might not bother me as much
but yeah um the audiences liked it too
much that didn't do too well at the box
office did it
um it did okay it seemed like it um
it it got like it got real mixed like
people either really loved it or really
hated it yeah that's what i could tell
from the vibe from the audience did
y'all ever review midsummer yeah we did
one
when it came out in the theater it was
another one that flopped at the box
office but
i liked it i liked it too i thought it
was awesome and that was another one
that
you really have to watch it again
because there's like so much [ __ ]
symbolism and all this other kind of
[ __ ] going on if you like um
if you like the wicker man you'd like
that yeah i liked all that neofolk stuff
yeah
very pagan horror i like yeah 79 million
at the box office zach says
okay and i'm not really sure i mean i
don't think it costs that much to make
so that's yeah so that's not bad for a
horror movie actually especially one is
weird is that
yeah the average p the average person uh
hated mid-summer
though yeah but average people yeah they
didn't even know what to make
especially in florida average people are
still they have no idea i don't think
that's what i mean it's like that's
that's why i don't really care like
oh did the movie do well at the box
after so i'm like yeah but most people
are idiots
so that doesn't mean that i'm gonna not
like it yeah florida's culture is
basically half [ __ ] kind of
cube and kind of south americans and
they had no idea what to make of that
movie well and florida's full of
rednecks and rednecks yeah they wouldn't
know what to make
that movie i mean rednecks wouldn't go
see that movie yeah they wouldn't it
wouldn't be there in the first part
in the first place
yeah yeah that's what i mean
all that european [ __ ] all that
european stuff where's the monster
trucks
i mean you know i couldn't do that to me
i just get my truck that's yeah
that's exactly what it would be like it
would be like i grew up like around
people like that yeah so i i know what
people are like that so
yeah that's why i don't really take it's
like the average person doesn't like
this it's like
yeah but the average person is stupid so
i don't really care about what they like
or don't like
you know what i mean somebody said also
uh sinister and insidious were also
written and i agree those were actually
worth really good
sinister actually surprised me i've been
hearing so much about that
um and ethan hawk is in it and i kind of
i don't know i have a soft spot for
ethan hawk
um i guess at all those [ __ ] 90s
movies he was in like he was in reality
bites and all that kind of [ __ ]
i think uh but yeah what i was like
actually surprised at how
good that was like how creepy that was i
think i like sinister more than
insidious now are the sinister
sequels any good because i keep i'm
tempted to watch them
i've only seen the first one i think
this the
part two is maybe on shutter or to be i
can't remember
and i keep seeing it and i'm like maybe
i should watch that because the first
one was really good
but i don't know it's like i always i
always watch the [ __ ]
sequels and they always kind of
disappoint me so i don't know but i did
really like that one
he says two is very good okay well maybe
i will watch it
did you guys review the witch 2015 i
don't think we ever did but
um i i don't think you saw it i
loved the witch it was so
creepy
it was like set back in um [ __ ] i can't
remember what year it was but it was
like it was set back in like colonial
times kind of
and uh it was all everything was um was
exactly like
period accurate like the way they talked
and like all their clothes and
all that other kind of stuff and it was
just like a really creepy
like witchcrafty kind of thing with like
a goat that was like
called black peter like telling them to
do things and it was
yeah it was super creepy i really really
liked it but that was kind of another
one
that's like you know i hate to use the
term prestige horror but it was like
another one of those
i think it might be on netflix now that
i'm thinking about it
um if anybody hasn't seen it but i
really really liked it that's another
one that i kind of want to rewatch
because i think it was like a year or
two
that i saw goat size are scary in real
life they are they have that like weird
pupil that like goes the opposite way
yeah
why did that happen i was reading an
article you know what's weird is i was
reading an article
a couple years ago about why that
happened and now i can't
remember i know one thing though is you
know i've taken care of them before
at barnes and staples and [ __ ] they're
friendly they're like dogs
and they aren't they're intelligent they
do [ __ ] and they [ __ ] play little
games and they
they're cute
and they descend from uh an ancient
predator
actually dude what you're seeing now was
not the first version
the first version of them was the size
of a horse yeah
and it had a head and on it and teeth
like a lion
and it ran around [ __ ] chasing [ __ ]
down and eating it
yeah you know they were [ __ ]
predators that was uh you know
millions of years ago that was before
humans but it's
it's hard to believe that that came from
a lion-like creature
yeah it's a trip it had clothing hooves
like the devil yeah cloven hooves with
teeth like a lion
yeah the witch was the same director as
the lighthouse
you saw the playhouse yeah that was good
i wouldn't want to see it again but that
was good
i liked that a lot had a weird ending it
was much funnier than i was kind of like
being insane watching that movie
well yeah well then it succeeded because
i think that's what he was trying to do
right
oh yeah you're right okay so black peter
is the blackface christmas guy the goat
is black phillip
that's right that's right blackville i
said black peter because we were talking
about
i was reminded of that [ __ ] christmas
creature show we did like a few years
back we were talking about black peter
like walking around a what [ __ ]
country does that it's so [ __ ] crazy
[Laughter]
wasn't that like isn't that like holland
it's somewhere like that
denmark i can't remember where it was i
was like reading um
oh [ __ ] david sedaris he i have one of
his like books of
essays and i think there's an essay in
there called six to eight black men
and it was kind of about like these
weird christmas traditions but like
it's like flapping like pulling sleighs
and
[ __ ] like that it was funny as hell i
have to [ __ ] read that [ __ ] again it
was so so [ __ ] yeah they asked me
yeah goats were
goats originally were something kind of
like a lion and it was the size of a
horse
killer goat that's the next sci-fi
original movie yeah that was a long long
time ago though
that was that was even before humans and
australopithecus it was a long time ago
yeah so it is holland because they have
zwarte pieces of march
which i guess is black peter but i think
that it's more than one country that has
that but it's kind of all those
countries up there like holland belgium
and all that yeah
[Laughter]
all right so uh you ready to shut it
down
we had a quick visit i guess yeah well i
mean it's sunday and we'll be our bull
stream again tomorrow probably another
new movie if i can find
one worth watching or one not worth
watching that's just
stupid and entertaining trauma gonna
need to make a movie based on killer
goats
i it would shock me if they hadn't
already but
i mean with those eyes you'd think that
would be like super terrifying
like up at giant's eyes what if it was
like a godzilla
like goatzilla i don't know i don't know
what you're talking about what could
they could make a movie called godzilla
they probably made something like that
yeah somebody tell me
that that's already been made it had to
have been because think how scary that
would be like a huge like godzilla sized
goat coming at you with those big
eyeballs
like they could even have a scene where
like one of those weird big eyes is like
in the [ __ ] window of like the high
rise
like looking in your apartment window
and [ __ ] like that i'm writing the movie
in my head as
we speak all right so uh we're gonna
shut it down i guess because it's sunday
and we're still kind of tired and
yeah not too hungover but just kind of
sleepy um
and we'll probably be back uh around 3
p.m tomorrow like i said either doing a
sidetracks or a
matinee which i guess this one was kind
of a sidetrack statement even though we
did kind of talk about a movie
uh but yeah we'll talk to you guys again
tomorrow so thanks for
coming by bye